hello everyone and welcome to round 11
of the 2022 feeder candidates tournament
where amazing things are happening it is
versus yaniponishi and uh if you guys um
for forgot or or haven't even seen the
standings you can uh uh janipomshi is
leading defeated candidates tournament
with seven points out of ten which is
just amazing and alireza currently in
last place with four out of ten points
but if he beats ian here then he will
well not only improve his own standings
but he will give chances for uh players
like quran and nakamura and the ding to
catch up to nepo because there are still
four more games to be played in defeated
candidates tournament it's not like it's
already over uh but even though it's an
incredibly intense moment in the feeder
candidates tournament everyone is
basically just talking about how alireza
played 250
bullet games yesterday evening uh
instead of you know just resting and
preparing for his game against tian so
how will this uh work out for him let's
check it out and see so alireza with the
white pieces opens with e4 we have pawn
to e5 knight to f3 and knight to f6
again jan goes for the petrov defense
and so far no one uh was able to even
make a tiny dent in in the armor or that
is the petrol of defense ian is wearing
uh fabi uh made some progress but it was
nowhere near uh you know getting
anything serious and in the end even
though fabi surprised nipple nipple was
the one who you know was okay with time
fabi was the one in in time control so
it's very interesting to see what
alireza has prepared knight captures an
e5 d6 knight to f3 and knight captures
an e4 so nothing out of the ordinary
here and here the standard ideas are d4
and knight to c3 and this is something
that you will see very often uh even in
a world change championship match for
example between magnussen and caruana
but here we have c for by alireza and
that is this is the fifth most popular
reply by white here and it is uh well it
is somewhat rare but not uh not you know
completely rare even nipple played this
move with the white piece against long
haul in 2016 and won a very nice game it
was a blitz game so not maybe uh
candidates uh
worthy but alireza prepared it and uh
let's see let's see
what comes next knight to c6 by nipple
d3 chasing away the knight knight f6 and
now pawn to d4 so wasting time a little
bit here but grabbing more space and
controlling a lot of squares here and
even d5 might be coming and if you were
worried about this uh you would just
play d5 but nipple says nope yeah you
are free to free to push some pawns here
if you want so bishop to e7 d5 by all it
is knight to e5 and here we have knight
to d4
and knight to d4 is a new move so
already as of move 9 we have a
completely new game instead of knight to
e4 there is a game from the feed a
women's world cup uh last year uh where
alexander kostanuk played the bishop to
e2 and she defeated tanjongi uh but like
i said knight the d4 is a new move so
already as of move nine completely new
game let's see how jan uh deals with
this position as probably the the the uh
he is the world's top authority under
under petra of defense we have castles
by that's not a castle sorry castles by
nipple uh knight to c3 and bishop to g4
now attacking alireza's queen we have f3
chasing away the bishop and also
controlling some squares here so the
knight won't be able to just jump around
bishop back to d7 and now bishop to e2
and here uh c6 attacking well it is a
strong center
his king is still in the center of the
board so it make makes sense to open up
the position uh so all it is are castles
c characters on the e5 c captures and
queen to b6 now uh hindering the
development of the dark square bishop
but also just putting pressure on the on
the d for knight here
uh and uh although you want to play
something like f4 uh if you play this
even moves like rook f the e8 are
possible because because of this pin you
don't really care about captures after
captures you will win back your piece so
it's a
funny position the king definitely does
not belong in g1 alert moves it he plays
king to h1 and now rook ate the c8 nepo
just continues development and now comes
the move that everyone was just like wow
that what a move because everyone was
expecting f4 you played king to h1 or of
course you want to play f4 and kick away
uh nepo's knight from this beautiful e5
square but uh instead of f4 alireza
plays pawn to g4 and this is just
uh this is just spectacular uh how ha ha
how can this be uh we have h6 nipple
says okay what do you do here uh just
second i think middle wants to come in
the room
yeah it was definitely definitely him
where were we oh yeah uh so h6 and this
is a very very annoying move when
someone plays against you you know you
play f3 you play g4 you want to play h4
you just you know you want to attack and
they play h6 and how are you continuing
this attack now g5 doesn't really make
all that much sense
but all it is uh you know uh stops here
thinks a little bit about the position
and plays h4 because here there really
isn't uh a move that can be considered
good it's just a better position for jan
objectively uh but still you know you
can play it it's not a lost position for
ali he's just uh you know opened up his
king uh uh maybe a bit too much and the
situation on the clock is 44 minutes for
alireza and an hour and 20 minutes for
yan so even though already the one who
surprised diana with the opening uh
again jan uh is up on up on time as
usual in pretty much every game so rook
f38 making some room for the king here
also bishop f8 can be played to help out
with the defense of the king if needed
and alireza continues attacking g5 and
already a very very rich position where
you could actually play a whole lot of
things uh jan went for the
straightforward h captures and g5 but
just to show you how
how fun the position is you can even
play knight to g6 and now uh after the
knight is captured for example g
captures on f6 and bishop characters
it's uh
almost impossible to hold this with
white you're down a piece but you're
attacking the knight here once the
knight moves you're going to play queen
d8 this is the move you have to find and
now
white's just going to get checkmated not
a lot you can do here in id4 you're
going to make room for the queen queen
captures this is coming if you defended
queen e1 then rook to c2 and it's just
um
not possible to hold this with white so
this is in the position but john went
for the straightforward h captures and
g5 h captures and now knight to h5
putting pressure on that g3 square
so king the g2 by alireza and now the
situation on the clock 36 minutes
foreign in an hour and 20 minutes for
nepo he pretty much
spent no time here and the position is
winning for nipple and there's even a
moment uh of this um
of this situation that is here uh there
you have it this is the the when alireza
played king to g2 yan just put himself a
nice um cup of coffee i imagine it's
coffee could be anything else really uh
and just gave alireza you know the stare
and
which means that he's ready to calculate
this out and that he he knows the latest
that lost it it's only a matter of
calculating precisely
and he finds it and of course uh the
move is knight to g6 i don't want to ask
you to pause and uh find it because i'm
sure you guys will find this one i have
a better one for you but yeah knight's
the g6 because uh we we want to take
care of the f4 square and now if you put
a knight on f4 it's uh basically game
over so all it is a has to play f4 which
is fine that's exactly the move he wants
to play and he plays it but now knight h
captures on f4 ian sacrifices the knight
uh and what uh can eliza do here well
capturing with the bishop is the only
move you could also capture with the
rook but it's not much better so bishop
captures an f4 now queen captures on b2
attacking the knight uh now the knight
is attacked twice and also putting
pressure on this bishop the king is also
on the second rank uh and alireza plays
knight to e4 and here uh is the position
that uh well everyone was so amazed with
uh everyone thought that jan was just
gonna play it everyone thought that jan
saw the solution yeah even before
playing that knight the g6 move uh but
that's actually not true uh something
completely different happened but you
guys are you know
in your homes comfortable you know maybe
maybe on your phones somewhere
[Applause]
if you can spare the time feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
incredible idea jan missed while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
incredible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is bishop
the d8 that's the move and you know it's
it's one thing to find the move with the
night back but finding a move with the
bishop back that's uh that's just uh
something on a whole different level uh
because now white doesn't really have a
move it seems like you have many great
moves you could capture on d6 attack the
both of the rooks you could play queen
to d2 or for a queen trade but none of
it really works if you play queen d2 we
simply trade queens uh
knight cap queen captures knight
captures and now we eliminated this guy
with check
rook captures and not bishop captures on
g5 attacking the rook you can't move the
rook because the knight hangs and this
is resigns you could try giving up the
exchange but it's it's really not all
that impressive captures captures rookie
five
uh goes after the pawn uh you can see
that uh
okay you uh white does have two knights
for the rook but uh
black is up black is up three pawns
you're gonna win more pawns here and
it's just gonna be impossible uh to hold
this so that's one way to play it and
the other way instead of trading queens
if you just go for the straightforward
knight captures on d6 then the point is
we go for rook captures on e2 and now
after knight captures on e2 we bring the
other rook into the attack rook the c2
attack the knight the knight can't move
also knight captures and f4 is always a
threat and if you defend the knight and
there's really not all that much you can
do knight captures an f4 with check and
just everything falls apart if night
captures we capture here and now you are
a very very
uh close to being checkmate it's
actually a mate in five from here so
that was the way to do it uh bishop to
d8 a very very sneaky backwards move uh
that nipple missed he played rook to c4
which is also a nice practical move but
uh you know the afian spent actually
some time here he would have found
bishop to d8 but the yan just plays
instantly here uh you know even though
it's a candidates tournament amazing
stuff yeah so bishop back to e3 you you
want to get the bishop away from f4 and
also defend your knight but now comes
bishop captures on g5 and here alireza
finds rook the b1 it is the only move
that
allows allows him to even continue the
game uh the situation on the clock 20
minutes for all it is 55 minutes for
nipple uh queen captures an a2 rook to
a1 and now already is hoping for a nice
repetition here if queen b1 if queen b2
rule b1 uh queen to a2 rook to a1 and so
on uh but nipple plays rook captures on
d4 there's even a nicer try here that's
really awesome
bishop captures an e3 comes with a queen
offering but it would be impossible for
white to survive this for example rook
captures an a2 now you play rook
captures on d4 and the white doesn't
have a good move you either move the
queen and then we're gonna win another
piece or you give up uh you know you you
move the knight or you try to give up
the queen at least to grab the rook or
something but basically trying to save
the queen allowing rook captures on e4
the white king will not survive here
amidst all of all of the pieces so
that's one way to do it ian does not
sacrifice the queen he plays rook
captures on d4 offers a queen trade
basically rook captures on a2 and now
again the bishop captures and e3 is
possible but the unjust goes for the
straightforward rook captures on d1 uh
bishop captures on d1 and now bishop
captures an e3 we have knight captures
on d6 attacking the rook and now rook to
e7 the only move that allows yanta
sort of play for the win because you
have to
guard the the f7 square so rook to e7
and now you have to play
you have to play it with engine
precision if you want to survive this
and the way to do that is to play rook
to e2 and prepare rook to e1 that's the
point because if if we move the bishop
and the rooks get traded off then again
f7 falls and alireza gets his draw but
here for example f6 king to f3 putting
pressure on the bishop knight to h for
check king the g3 now g5 it would be
something like this incredibly difficult
to play with white because uh you really
don't have all that many moves uh but it
was the only choice if you capture on f6
it doesn't matter king g7 rook is going
to go back we're going to play b5 start
pushing the two pass pawns on the queen
side and with the king being so
vulnerable on g3 it's hard to imagine
you can survive this in a practical game
but okay already played bishop to b3 and
now is just uh instant resigns uh
without this pressure on the bishop here
there's just nothing to play for so jan
moves it bishop to c5 attacks the knight
here knight captures on b7 and bishop to
b6 we have bishop to see for aleris are
trying to activate the bishop a little
bit because he's also incredibly low on
time he has some three minutes on the
clock whereas jan has like 40 minutes uh
rook to e3 now uh
making the the the square that the white
king can use uh fewer and fewer
king the h1 and now comes bishop to h3
attacking the rook here rook to c1 and
now bishop to f5 preparing bishop to e4
check and there's no good way to defend
this bishop to f1 bishop to e for check
and it was in this position unmoved 35
that alireza firuja resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
if you block with the bishop then rook
to h3 is checkmate there's no way to
avoid this the bishop's pair is just
incredible here and if you don't you
well there's not all that much you can't
play if play king g1 you go under the
mask of the bishop then all sorts of
nasty discoveries are possible young
just gobbles up whatever he wants and if
king the h2 which is your only other
option then just bishop captures and the
five attacks the knight attacks the rook
here you're gonna
suffer heavy material loss uh this is
resigns
so yeah bishop to e4 already resigns and
another brilliant victory for
yanipanishi in the feeding candidates
tournament 2022 and now it's gonna be
very very difficult to catch on uh he
would have to you know mess up his last
three rounds in you know to a great
extent to even allow others to you know
catch up to him which is not impossible
but you know if if he continues playing
the way he played the first 10 games
then i think uh he he has nothing to
worry about
uh but yeah uh crazy stuff from alireza
had a you know perfectly normal
possession and you know instead of going
for f4
you know something that you would expect
then maybe be three the fiance putting
the bishop on a long diagonal he goes
for g4 and ian just uh well jan
basically destroys him uh it was a if
young didn't find this uh incredible
knight to g6 move just uh preparing the
knight sacrifice after all it is a place
f4 then alireza has a game and it could
go uh either way but after knight the g6
this is just uh uh you know resigns for
alireza basically and as it usually is
it's always a move with the knight back
so yeah that's the game hope you guys uh
enjoyed it tough break for alireza uh
but an incredible uh you know increase
in in uh leadership for for yanipanishi
we'll see we'll see how it goes we're
gonna cover other games from round 11 as
well and then we're going to discuss the
standings uh i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to nashi and i would like
to thank clever piggy ordell and teddy
forever uh michael hope consulting and
alan chevalier moore for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day